So what's the difference between a pure strategy and
a mixed strategy, Michael? Well, it's, it's simply this.
A mixed strategy, simply implies, or means, some distribution,
over strategies. So in the case of two strategies,
like we have here, where you can either, A
can be either a resigner or a holder, we're
going to simply say that the mixed strategy for A
is some value for P. Which is the probability
of choosing to be a holder. So do you, you see
what's going on here? So the only difference between a mixed
strategy and a pure strategy. Is that for a mixed strategy,
you choose some probability over all the different strategies that you
might choose. So you decide that, you know, going into this
I'm going to flip a coin. And half the time I'm going to
be a resigner, and half the time I'm going to be a
holder. Say. Or 30% of the time I'll be a resigner.
And 70% of the time I'll be a holder. Okay?
>> Yep.
>> Where as with pure strategies, you always chose
on or the other. So technically, it's the case
that a pure strategy's also a mixed strategy where
all the probability mass is on a single strategy.
>> Makes sense.
>> So in this case we're going to, in
fact, choose P to represent the probability for
A of choosing to be a holder rather than a resigner. And so P can be
0%, probability zero, or can be probability one, or
any value in between. You with me on that?
>> Yeah, that's neat.
>> Okay, good. To make certain you understand this I'm going to give you
a little quiz. Which I have up here on the screen. You ready?
>> Oh, I see it. [LAUGH] It's like those, those very square boxes.
>> Yes.
>> I didn't even realize what, what, what this could be about.
>> It certainly couldn't be a quiz because Charles has never drawn a straight
box in his life. I had drew those Michael. It took me 17 hours.
>> Oh man, you are, you're committed to this and I appreciate that.
>> I am committed to this. Okay, so,
given that we have a mixed strategy, and we
have a probability P of A being a holder,
here's my question for you. In a world where
B is a resigner, okay? B is always
going to choose to resign. What is A's expected profit?
To make it easy for you, I copied the
matrix over here in the upper right hand corner.
>> Wait, wait, wait. If B
is always a resigner.
>> B is always a resigner.
>> Then, what's, and what is A?
>> A is going to choose to be a holder with probability P.
>> Oh, so you want this to be a function of P.
>> Maybe.
>> If it's, if it's, okay, sure, maybe [LAUGH]. It could, well, I mean, yes.
It's a function of P, it just might be a constant function that ignores P.
>> It could be, in principle. Okay, now, after you figure
that out, I want you to decide, in a world where B
is the seer, B always chooses to see the card. What would A's expected profit
be, in a world where A will choose to be a holder with probability p. Okay?
>> Hm.
>> Got it?
>> And that's going to be, oh yeah, that could be different
because it's a it's a different strategy, though you know seering.
>> Yes
>> Like like if you're a resigner you're a resigner, but
if you're a seer then what you are doing is seering
>> Mm-hm.
>> That would be an anagram of resigner.
>> How do you see
these things?
>> I don't know. They're just there. I just,
they words just kind of mix themselves up. Alright anyway,
I'm, I think I am ready to do the
function. I'm, I'm ready to stop looking at the letters.
>> Okay? And go!